in this crazy mixed-up world amusement
parks can be our escape from the trials
of our normal lives the smell of popcorn
the deafening roar of rollercoasters it
all makes me happier than a kid in the
candy store but if there's one thing I
love more than visiting amusement parks
it's building them roller coaster tycoon
star that love affair for me back in
1999 and the newest game by UK developer
frontier looks a continuing now the guys
at frontier are no strangers to theme
park games they're responsible for many
of the roller coaster tycoon games as
well as thrill ville scream ride and
several other mobile titles the last
couple of years found them working on
the sci-fi epic elite dangerous but with
their new game planet coaster they've
returned to the theme park building sim
world and they're looking to reclaim the
throne as coaster building king
newcomers to the genre will find it easy
to start building right away as the
game's friendly UI makes it easy to
construct their own park from scratch
there are quite a few pre-made shops and
coaster tracks that just plop down in
front of a walkway as well as tons of
scenery options to fill out all the
empty space in between rides but like
any good simulation game it's when you
take a closer look at the details does
planet coaster truly shine the game
offers levels upon levels upon levels of
micromanaging from staff training to
refurbishing rides to even the salary of
your burger vendor your park is truly
your own and planet coaster does an
amazing job by giving you all the
control you could ever want
in addition planet coaster offers an
unprecedented of customization right
down to the rotation of your garden
lights the game gives you complete
control over every little detail in the
park and thanks to the Steam Workshop
the games developers have opened the
door for seemingly unlimited
possibilities with user-generated
content by embracing the modding
community people are now able to create
and share their own personal concoctions
with players all over the world in
developer interviews frontières stated
that they're focusing a lot of their
attention on the individual guests
unlike a lot of other simulation games
they're not
taking any shortcuts in making the parks
guests just as important as the rest of
the game
everything from the individual character
designed to the crowd fluidity to the
walk emotions have all been crafted with
the utmost care injecting some
much-needed personality into the genre
and because of the effort put into
making them feel like actual people
rather than just mindless cash drones
the game feels so much more alive
now I love the original rollercoaster
tycoon
it's one of my favorite games of all
time but that game was all about the
park it was about building the coolest
coasters and rides and making the most
money in the sense it was all about the
business sure the game supplied hundreds
upon hundreds of people to populate your
park but they were mostly there for
giving you money and vomiting all over
the place in fact now that I think about
it the people in these tycoon games feel
more like a responsibility than anything
else you entertain them you clean up
after them you keep them safe most of
the time and while it's true that the
main goal is to get them to enjoy the
park and all the rides in it the only
way that they can validate their
enjoyment is with their wallet of course
that doesn't take anything away from the
game tycoon games have been and always
will be about the business they're about
money first and people's second which is
why planet coaster feels so special to
me it's a simulation game focused around
the experience of being in a theme park
rather than owning one you might not be
the actual guests but more than ever you
can feel what they feel as you put your
finishing touches on a ride that you
spend hours constructing the payoff is
not only monetary but also emotional you
can see the guests reactions while
riding a coaster whether they're
enjoying it or screaming terror they'll
run towards newly opened rides hoping to
be first in line and hey remember that
burger vendor whose salary we increased
we actually see her enthusiasm for
working there
in the game not just as a colored bar
that says happy yes you still have to
manage your finances wrangle your park
staff and occasionally deal with the
tidal wave puke but the game's
presentation might be the defining
feature planet coaster seeing the guests
excitement and reaction to rides things
that I have built myself and spent hours
upon hours creating is way more
rewarding than any profit chart could be
and when the game can connect to me on a
personal level especially one coming
from a genre that glorifies staring at
numbers and charts it's done something
right so while other themed Park games
have encountered some problems as of
late it's comforting to know that
another game will be there to step up
and leave the amusement parks image
planet coaster is a game that rose out
of necessity and it looks to fill that
gaping hole in my heart that so many
previous theme park games left behind
the game is beautiful it's deep and it's
every bit as fun as the first roller
coaster tycoon was for me over 15 years
ago for more on plan coaster and
everything else video games stay tuned
the GameSpot and thanks for watching
you